hi I'm Chris I make music and videos and
I'm his big brother 9 Chris's little
brother buddy together with two-thirds
of Simba's the meijer halts brothers
mashup electro beats with the sounds of
the Caribbean while themselves having
roots in yet another part of the world
another controlling our mothers from
South Korea's assets a third of the way
around the globe to Germany unifor
schlund their mother moved to
braunschweig in 1974 and worked as a
nurse she then met her future husband
alopecia d where typical for half
koreans from our generation as in born
between the late 70s and mid 80s a nurse
for a mother finished high school and we
learn to play piano and violin one each
we did everything right except we didn't
become doctors or lawyers in 2011 the
brothers founded a project then still
called Simba's sound from the outset
they put a big focus on the
visualization of their music their 2012
singled the downfall one best music
video at the UK film festival
today but in Chris live in Berlin's hip
and multicultural quoits bad
neighborhood it was here that they met
ZM see the Vietnamese Chinese German
rapper who became the third part of
Simba's the three share a love of
Caribbean music their diverse roots have
made the musicians open to all
influences Louis yeah Tim before selling
off we grew up aware that there's never
only one way for things to work in zynga
Frandsen une semaine de semana attentive
good the fact that there's always an
alternative makes us interested in those
other options Alan alternative no matter
where you come from about the same
uniforms any warrior status on geometry
AKA CMC wraps to the beats laid down by
buddy and chris in their studio these
parents belong to a wave of refugees in
the late 1970s call the vietnamese boat
people the refugee issue is as a cute as
ever with Germany alone taking in
several hundred thousand from the
war-torn Middle East zzzz family made it
to safety which is why he's eager to
help today's refugees come on itunes and
my parents fled vietnam in 1978 they
became friends here with the german
couple helped them to settle down
leading go home on your and food
supplies and Ishod Kedar as a flash
dusky i thought it was right to do that
myself help refugees to get permits and
maybe the right to stay in Germany like
my parents you inflate doctrine by him
to do it from a human hair done in
addition to festivals in Europe Simba's
have performed in South America and Asia
and have been to the west bank and
Zimbabwe as part of an initiative run by
the German government
movie movie or something I think it's
cool to have this official program
showing that side of Germany here in the
koi bag district of Berlin at least it's
a lot closer to reality than your
stereotypical the varian Simba's are
ambassadors of a multicultural Germany
March sees the release of their second
album Airport accent and the Asian
German trio will soon be jetting off to
take it on tour